hello and welcome to this episode of the
visit of art school my name is Ryan
Minor ding I'm the head of visual
development at Marvel Studios I sort of
spend my days drawing and painting the
Marvel characters in for the MCU this
series of instructional videos are going
to start just talking about how to do
some drawing and painting how to draw
the characters and give you give you
guys a chance to sort of draw along with
us as well as hopefully at the end of it
giving you something that you could
print out and color it if you'd want to
drawing and painting is one of those
great joys of my life and it's it's one
of those things that hopefully you guys
can be inspired to do and so let's get
let's get drawing alright let's get
started drawing and talking about
drawing these characters so what type of
character are you trying to draw usually
breaks down very simply for comics into
heroes or villains and then once you've
answer that question what type of hero
are they or what type of villain are
they there's lots of different types of
heroes anything the difference between
the Hulk and Captain America and Iron
Man are they strong are they fast the
intelligent what type of villain are
they you know there are lots of
different types of villains as well and
one of the things with superheroes is
you have that great idea of like what
are the what are their powers and you
combine all of those things together
into pose posture expression and design
and lets you know each one of those
categories could really take an entire
you know course of discussion to talk
about let's start with poses with heroes
most poses that we try to work out have
a lot of into inherently heroic
characteristics we're trying to make
chests feel strong and shoulders feel
strong and and have the gesture of the
pose really make the character feel
powerful whether that's a running pose a
standing pose or a flying pose or a
jumping pose but but most of the time
we're we are trying to find strength is
it's sort of an inherent part of being a
superhero and where you
we trying to find ways of of making each
each characters unique unique strengths
visible in their poses when I do captain
america poses i'm usually trying to find
ways of making him feel heroic and Noble
as well a lot of times that translates
into you know looking off into the
distance sometimes it's sometimes it is
about a very specific type of expression
which we can talk about expressions in a
little bit when it's Iron Man
he has great flying poses but he also is
a very strong fighter and has the chest
Artie so anytime you can emphasize those
types of unique you know individualistic
characteristics of each character that'd
be that's one of the important points
another one is if they are gonna fly how
are they gonna fly you know modern man
needs his repulsors in order to fly so
how does a character with repulsors fly
differently than a character like
Captain Marvel who doesn't our doctor
stranger requires the the cloak of
levitation but the main point about this
is to define poses is sort of different
than postures postures are essentially
it's very simple opposes is is a is is
it's basically opposes something that
any character can achieve you know they
can they can they can throw a punch they
can run a posture is essentially what is
what is the the the basic gesture of the
character that's baked into that
character so the Hulk here for example
on the left has more of a hunched-over
posture and in something that would be
more like Captain Marvel on the right
has more of a sort of like a you know a
strong gesture of a proud gesture of
sticking her her shoulders back there's
lots more we could say about poses and
postures but moving on to expressions
just so they can get cover all these
you know fairly quickly expert I sort of
just drawing a base face here and in
order to put expressions on top of it
usually this is the way that I'll test
out different expressions on characters
if we're doing a unique character design
like like Thanos or the Hulk will do a
neutral face and then we'll do
expressions on top and I'm just doing a
sort of generic male face and then a
generic female face a lot of the a lot
of the structure of these types of
drawings can come from you know you can
look at any number of sources in the
comics as reference there's also great
instructional books from Andrew Loomis
that talk about different structures of
those face Bridgman is another great
artist that did great instructional
books on on figure drawing and and you
know but generally speaking you know
it's about trying to find find a
personality or character within within
each face that you draw and it make it
look like that characters looking back
at you once I have these these heads
more or less to a place where they're
reasonable I'll start doing expressions
so the first I'm going to do for it was
more of an anger expression dropping the
brows a little bit this making the eyes
squint a little bit and turning the
mouth
downward so it has more of a scale to it
there are easy ways to get you know
expressions to read smiles time to turn
the mouth upward which is maybe an
obvious one but the the notion of adding
smile lines as well as making the eyes a
little bit squinty basically people
smile with their eyes a lot they also
relax their eyebrows sometimes and get
more of a ball of a cheek on their face
and now into surprise eyebrows go up the
eyes get wider so we essentially have
you can see more of the whole circle of
the iris and and some white of the eye
above the iris and in this sadness which
is raising the brows in the center
and having that sort of upturn line
coming off of the top of the eye as well
and usually the mouth is a down turned
one and then getting into since we're
doing superheroes the notion of in your
extreme extreme focus rage you know
anger fighting more of an extreme
extreme expression having the mouth be
open and revealing the teeth and seeing
you black on either side of the teeth
really squinting the eyes dropping the
eyebrows quite a bit but usually you
know that all that is part if is
filtered through looking these different
expressions
what's the poser your character is doing
and what are they supposed to be
thinking and how can you make that
thought evident and basically their
their posture pose and expression the
final category that we're talking about
and again each one of these could really
take a whole course on each one of these
elements design is design is where that
can meet can apply almost into anything
and in this case what I'm talking about
is essentially the core structure of a
design of a face and then Captain
America's helmet which is what we're
gonna do when we actually get into
drawing a opposed figure doing a base
circle and then dropping sort of a
rectangle down for the jaw and and then
drawing a centre line is an important
part of drawing a face because knowing
you know which side - how far apart the
eyes are being able to judge the whole
face together
throwing the helmet on top I'm also
looking for lines that always point back
to the eyes and the the the ridges on
his helmet as well as the a both pointed
his eyes which are very useful design
tools but we're usually trying to find
you know as strong a jawline and sort of
very useful I think the word strong and
strength has come up a couple times when
I've been talking about this and it's
it's it's since they are super here is
we're trying to find those types of
strong qualities in the jaw line and in
the head shape so I'm gonna start
drawing a a actual posed character now
this is going to be a drawing of Captain
America usually starting with that that
circle again and then dropping down the
rectangle and chiseling it into a
triangle for the jaw finding the center
line and then drawing the the the brows
and the mouth on top of it that the
triangle that comes down from the
cheekbones down to the mouth is an
important set of lines as well because
it really defines that front plane as
strongly as possible we're you know when
you get into drawing characters and
faces like this trying to find the most
simple battles only two-dimensional read
for four characters but also the
three-dimensional read of that that
triangle of the other cheek bones that
come come down to the mouth is an
important and useful tool so after
having had an you know a basic
understanding of the the Captain America
helmet from the front view I'm now
retrying to recreate it in a
three-quarter and drawing the head first
is an important tool for me especially
with caps head because he's a unique
character not not a totally unique
character but you know you have a
character like Spider Man whose faces is
entirely covered with a mask cap said is
you know you see his eyes and you see
his mouth and nose but then you have to
also design the helmet over top of it or
draw the helmet over top of it and I I
usually have to draw as strong a you
know a head as I can on on his actual
for his face and then I draw the helmet
on top because I if I try to just draw
him at the same time it never seems to
work getting in there and detailing out
some of the you know the the iris and
the pupil and the eyelashes a lot of
that stuff really does help in and help
in defining the character and making
them feel a little bit alive
reinforcing the the jawline the chin
strap on Captain America is one of the
most helpful design elements for his
face because it really does give him a
really strong jaw line from from all
angles actually overemphasizes his jaw
line now I'm getting down into the body
you know trying to figure out how to
make his shoulders feel broad this
thinking about design as well as the the
straps on his shoulders point back to
his head which is always a great you
know thing thinking of the rib cage is a
big egg and sort of building all the
lines design lines off of that and also
with superheros that the the sort of V
that comes up off of the stripes and
into the his chest and PEC shape and
goes out to his shoulders is it's one of
those things it's just inherent in
almost every superhero you know trying
to find a way to make their their chest
feel strong their shoulders feel strong
and then all of these little details on
top are basically trying to make him
feel as real as possible you know
thinking of CAP as a soldier having sort
of gear and and pouches on his belt to
be able to go in to go into battle with
and doing his iconic shield maybe I ll
do a specific art school class about
about drawing his shield because he can
get it seems like it should be easy but
it's not as easy it seems as it seems
sometimes drawing the legs and finding
folds that make it feel like he has
weight on his legs angling the shield a
little bit more to really echo the
gesture of his of his arm and you know
finishing off the the sketch version of
his um of his arm and I'm trying to add
a little bit of smoke in the background
to just heighten the notion of what this
image is that him sort of maybe hearing
a call to action and turning to see
what's what's happening in a dramatic
situation and now since I've centrally
dropped the opacity on that on that
sketch and I'm drawing overtop of it to
find cleaner lines so it's basically the
idea of creating a an underlay drawing
that then you can go and put nicer lines
on top of because you don't have to
specifically worry about the placement
of everything it's it's sort of figure
it out for you that's one of the ways
that I do work a lot is figuring out you
know using rough sketches to to figure
out the the poses and
happening opposed the posture and
expression and the design and then going
back over it with sort of cleaner lines
or in some cases you know a full-on
photoshop painting in order to in order
to really make the the image feel like
it's real but a lot of this is finding
the the more specific and unique design
elements of CAP which is a lot of things
on his costume are you know tied into
the star shape even the design of his
stripes have become sort of nestled into
the the star shape and and most of those
lines that you know really emphasizing
the the the V the strong v quality and
and in his body to try and make him feel
strong I always enjoyed putting seams
and in and things on these costumes to
try and make them feel a little bit more
real and more structured and and making
him feel like there have been engineered
for for battle you know if you look at
designed for military clothing a lot of
the time those things are have lots and
lots of seams on them reinforced seams
to really make it sure that the you know
if a soldier's in battle but that um
that costume is not gonna is not going
to be the thing that falls apart for him
and then I'm going in and sort of trying
to figure out some some look for the
clouds if if I get a chance to really
really finish this off at some point I
might do some better lines and better
design shapes for clouds but I was
getting in the details on on caps head
and trying to figure out like what's the
best way to represent this ideally what
I'm gonna try and do here is create an
image that you guys can download and
and and print out and and color in if
you'd like so I don't want to fill in
everything says I don't want to take
away the possibility from you guys
coloring it but did feel like caps
helmet is pretty dark so I might as well
just fill in that a little bit so it it
becomes a focal point and you know you
end up being able to see him a little
bit and and because his his turtleneck
is a little dark that as well also
adding little hatch marks in different
places you know cap is one of those
characters who's almost you know from
the minute he he starts fighting he he's
a little bit dirty he gets he gets he
gets you know dirt on his face and and
and and different scuff marks on his
costume and his shield and and that is
an important part of his design as well
so I think there's a couple ways you can
treat this video I think you can treat
it as you know if you'd like to try and
give a shot of using it as instructional
video to try and draw your own version
of Captain America but you can also take
the the drawing that's been done and and
read it out and color it in if if you'd
like I'm just adding the sort of
finishing touches more again more scuffs
and scrapes and adding some some
additional details to the shields and I
think that that's pretty much the final
I hope you've enjoyed this version of
the visit of art school I hope you guys
have a great day